China has never really been explicit in
precisely defining its claims in the
South China Sea, or what it hopes to
achieve there. Still, it's possible to
discern some of China's objectives, and
fundamentally I think China wants to
control the waters of the South China Sea. It wants to dominate the South China Sea.
Why does it want that? First, doing so
would make it easier for China to defend
its southern coastline, which is home to
important economic centers on the mainland.
Secondly, dominating the South China Sea would allow China to more easily defend
against the blockades should a crisis ever
break out, while making it easier for it
to blockade others, especially Taiwan, Japan, and even South Korea. Third, dominating
the South China Sea would allow China to
more easily coerce and even project
force against its Southeast Asian
neighbors. And lastly, dominating the
South China Sea would give China a safe
bastion in which its ballistic missile
submarines could operate. If its nuclear
submarines can patrol in the South China
sea without having to worry about US
military assets tracking their every move,
it enhances nuclear deterrence vis a vis the United States. So what are your
thoughts about China's ambitions in the
South China Sea?
Let us know in the comments, and also let us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.